ladies
do you think that men
laughs
pretty much do you think men lack
masculinity nowadays and is that
something you look for
i don't really know like what is
masculinity today
like
anyways
i just think about like
being tall or being built like
athletically that's not even masculinity
like what do you guys define masculinity
as then i can tell you for lacking of it
sorry one more time i got like what do
you guys define masculinity as like
today like i don't even know where to
start
um i think of just like a traditional
like like when you think of traditional
masculinity like tough
man like maybe even assertiveness yeah
assertive like you know what leadership
i would say is the best way to describe
it so even if you plant like if you have
a date he's going to plan it he's going
to
take you out he wouldn't let you pay
like that's traditionally masculine i'm
not going to lie majority of the men
i've been in contact with or date have
been quite masculine so i wouldn't say
like men are lacking masculinity i do
feel like men make an effort like a
conscious effort to be masculine and i
don't think that many not many women do
that anymore
men are more driven to be more masculine
than women are driven to be feminine
okay okay what do you what do you is
that so would you say that because you
have dated traditionally masculine men
yeah like that's something that's
something you look for a little bit then
i guess so i think you're trying to do
something that's attractive yeah it's
probably evolutionary
it's just kind of funny because that's
kind of the opposite of what you were
saying earlier
i feel like there's something
it's like what you want in an ideal
society and also like what biologically
you're capable of like there's stuff out
of my hands and stuff like
subconsciously my body wants to have
like what i want to have that i have no
choice against right and those are like
traditionally masculine men
traditionally assertive men member
confidence that kind of thing that's
kind of like an evolutionary trait
that's not to do with if i want equality
enough i want to have like
dating equality or like meant to be as
masculine as i want to be meant to be
emotional but obviously biologically
i can i can't go against my biological
edges and things like that right right
what about you eileen um i do like um
you know like
hand on the shoulder
no yeah i mean like you know for them to
like lead or what i think it's like
attractive obviously but i mean i don't
need them to do it like all the time
you know like paying for dates that's
attractive but you know i will also like
i would also like be like oh like let me
or probably like secretly do it so that
they don't try to like you know do it
also like i don't know let's let's split
up and just be like oh i'm just going to
pay for it
um
yeah
okay so you know it doesn't seem like
that's huge for you and what you look
for would you say your exes have been
more traditionally masculine
my what your exes and like the guy
you're dating now um
no i mean
i feel like you know it's funny because
i wouldn't say like i have a type
just looking back on it i guess i do
because i feel like um maybe i just kind
of like put it in there like i don't
want there to just be one leading person
right clearly it's not the problem
huh heights clearly not being the
problem
anyways
like i would say like i'm a pretty
not like boss
woman or boss what do you call it like
an emancipated woman like you make your
own decisions yeah i'm not i'd like to
be yeah i like to be very independent i
like to not
let the man like only do their thing i
like to be the one to also like chip and
do my part dude that's like your
personality because like here like well
the women on this table we're quite
independent we make our own decisions we
have our own things going on we're quite
career-minded i don't think we're very
representative of all women out there so
think there are women that probably want
different things
as an independent person you kind of
want someone else that's also
self-confident and has their own thing
going for them has their own ambitions
like i'm quite an ambitious woman and i
feel like you guys are as well yeah so i
think that kind of like translates into
what we look for we're looking for men
that also have those traits too yes and
that happens to be masculine as well
yeah is that
an accident is that a coincidence like i
don't know you know because i also like
it when they don't mind me also maybe
leading some of the time yeah and i
think that's where like the 50 50 comes
in mind where like maybe my type is
someone that likes to leave but also
doesn't mind it when someone else leads
what's an example of a time where you
led in a relationship
um
let's see i would say like you know
literally just like planning the whole
day like picking a place to go like how
we'll go what time we'll go
i mean it's not even like a big thing
yeah i know i understand so you enjoyed
doing that yeah i like like i mean
especially since i don't know i like
picking out like where to go eat like
you're organized like i've played this
thank you i wouldn't say so but i mean
maybe just because i'm
a little or maybe or maybe you're just
with the new all the time so she's maybe
she's
you know like picking like i i don't
know i think planning dates are fun so
so can i
ask questions yeah
is that expected of you in your
relationship like no i don't think
i don't think anything should be
expected in a relationship i think
like there shouldn't be expectation i
mean i mean okay
don't let me say that actually
okay
um like dates i don't think there should
be like
i should be planning everything i should
be doing everything it should be i'd
like to have that 50 philly 50 50
balance for everything yeah honestly 50
50 for everything everything was yeah
interesting how do you feel do you have
a back like a follow-up question just i
just wanna get the opinions i do feel
like
i would like to have some choice in like
what we're doing we're not saying it's
not a hundred percent either way we're
just saying so
so i'm not saying i won't say 50 50 but
i would say like in my like day in life
i would like that both people are having
some sort of input like oh like it's
sunny today let's do something outside
and then maybe he chooses a place that's
outside like that kind of like just
having some sort of input that's not
just like okay today we're going here
tomorrow we're going here the next day
we're doing this that you don't really
have much inputs i feel like
modern times like
i feel like we can have that kind of
balance now self pro how do you feel
um
i prefer the guy leads
um
but
trying to think yeah i mean i wouldn't
go on a holiday like
i'm kind of in a different situation
just because i know um
i'll be okay
because um
putting the host on the spot right now
like i i know i'm gonna inherit a good
chunk of change so it's like i know
he doesn't really have to provide like
that you know i mean
um but
i mean i prefer like guys that are like
more decisive
the reason why i said questions because
you said you don't mind doing this
whatever you know well i just wanted to
get to a point where is it you don't
mind because you're not expected to do
it it's not you it's not what tradition
expected so because it's only once in a
blue moon it's fun to do it sometimes
whereas the guy it's the expectation you
do this do that so i guess the level of
pressure is different so do something
sometimes it's fun something something
do something all the time isn't or may
not be i don't know i personally i like
planning
things sometimes like
um i feel like trips is fun to plan like
i think i i i'd rather take lead when we
planned like a trip if you're going
abroad i would like to be more in
control because i kind of have more i
don't know i feel like i'm more
experienced in like traveling and things
like that like do what you're good at i
would technique there yeah what about
what do you feel like about the
stereotype where women like you know
when you have the um when you like move
into your house and stuff like that how
do you feel about those stereotypes
being like women are like the decorators
like you know me like putting weight
together but like
like
we are i just generally want to know
about this i just really want to know
that i feel like i should take lead
there because i feel like i've seen
men's interior design if you go into any
guy's room
i'm sorry like they've got the basics
going but a lot of men don't really pay
attention to designs
the reason why i asked this year is
because like unless he's an interior
designer
when like the things don't even wrong
like your imagination when it comes to
decorating the colors the stuff like
that like i take your hats off you're
like yeah you got it yeah but it's just
the man's gotta put up with that like
you you got your man working all the
time moving the couch thirty centimetres
to the left and then fifteen back like
it's it's but like at the end of the day
like the man's gonna be having my own
damn
[Music]
yeah but at the end of the day like
you're both gonna be sharing that space
i feel like
if he doesn't want something there like
you can talk about it but i think
majority of the time a woman has a
really good intuition for design yeah
but when we talk about it we sleep on
the couch that's
that's the problem yeah because the
guy's designer but yeah we have the tv
on the floor with like just one chair
and like his ps5 what's wrong with that
there's like this really happen
have you seen oh
i kind of got a thing for cheap guys
though so there's something about it
an empty apartment where i'm like you
hate spending money don't you me too
you know what it is you're like why do i
send super chats
you know what it was
what i've um come to find out um
recently actually um
there was i think what was it um i think
it was like elon musk one of like one of
the
the richest guys bridges guys right what
they have said was like
when up when a guy or or any person
right that has like when you don't have
like a clean room like a clean freaking
salad
the person that's like really the one
that be making the good box and like you
know in the future is the person with
the mess room because they keep in like
open mind about like they keep you just
like
i don't know kind of like what's the
hippie term for like that like i'll just
keep it like organized
bass yeah basically that yeah right
there because there's a lot of like
theories like maths and algorithms like
people that organize like say libraries
that
actually better than organizing
something so let's say you have the most
commonly read books put them on the
shelf to organize them back
actually waste time because you're
hiding the most commonly read books so
it's kind of better to have that
organized mess actually
just there so people that read those
books the most can have access to
describe my room that way
i would definitely describe my own
if you want to
organize mess is different from like
like unhygienic though yeah let's draw
that line
my bathroom is sparkly clean but like oh
clothes are on the you know the special
chair
there's always that one chair one [ __ ]
always
i have a question um for the women
do you guys find it attractive
do you guys find it attractive when men
know how to do like like when they're
handy and can do like traditional 100
percent 120 200 percent love myself
this one take him into my house
if you can if you can film me a house
let's get married like if you can build
a house
at me
um
okay you know she is tracking
hey i can all like that and then some
put it that way no because that is so
attractive um can neither of you can't
wait
can can neither of you build a house
for no no no i've been so
just yesterday just yesterday so you
could build up could you build a house
when i was when i was obviously when my
parents were it was a little bit
different time same way for you and for
everyone else but for me when i was
still raised i was still raised under
the like because obviously my family
luckily i was fortunate enough they have
a lumberjack business whether you know
your cut wood planks and all that stuff
they have a fishing business they have
uh mechanic businesses for that so i was
always raised around being like the
handys kind of reclaiming all the you
know everything that you need to be
basically to be a man this one is so
attractive now
it's not even no it's not it's not
enough the words got you baby
that's not even but that's the type of
stuff that i was brought up to from a
very young age and when i moved here
my
mentality was i got to go into like the
construction business so when i did high
school construction i did all the like
do you do you think that's because
you're from you're from lithuania yeah
so do you think it's oh you're about to
bring back the the background checks
it's more traditional there isn't it
would you say yes yeah absolutely uh
like men are generally in lithuania
mainly
generally if you don't if you have your
own business okay it's great like you
can be whatever you want to be in that
in that business you pay your own salary
but if you don't most men drift towards
um obviously construction uh a good road
works is very very well paid there um
just any sort of like a general hands-on
hands-on work yeah lumberjack is another
very good one especially in those
villages and stuff i don't know about
you guys i think like trades it's very
attractive to me very attractive it
shows like discipline yeah someone
that's working hard yeah yeah you're
working hard i don't care what you're
doing i agree i agree i respect it like
you don't have to have a degree like if
you're working hard and you have a skill
that you're good at and you're actually
good at it like you've mastered
something yeah so attractive that's what
i always say if i do dating advice to
guys like let her see something you're
good at yeah please yes please but the
thing is the term the term mastering a
skill is is taken like out of context
because
in in life right no matter how good you
are or something that's all in that area
there's always something you can improve
if you're good at it no yeah it's one
thing to say you're good at it but like
mastering i feel like is taken out of
context because
every day like you learn something new
no matter how good you are you could be
like the greatest maybe like someone
that's like not i mean i guess like
always trying to improve themselves
always trying to improve what they
already know you know it's better than
average like above average is one thing
and you should know that he's invested
time to learning this thing yeah it
doesn't have like it doesn't really
matter what it is if you dedicate time
to something you're going to be good at
it and better yeah yeah and i really
respect that because you've learned that
yourself so guys
i'll go ahead go ahead
would you date a plasterer or a plumber
120
yeah like okay
no one ever knows but they actually
earned the most money
i don't know what it is
[Applause]
okay
now now question for the man is it
attractive to you if a woman can like
cook and clean
and like like do the traditionally
feminine things traditionally
yes but not so much now because
obviously i feel i feel like personally
i'll be i'll be mutualistic i feel like
everyone at a certain age should learn
how to cook
like cook
just do the basics like cook clean up
take care of yourself yeah exactly
because yeah look
um i was raised in a house so my um dad
passed away before i was born so i was
raised in a house of women right so i
was always raised up of like respecting
women you know respecting their choice
all that stuff i've learned how to cook
clean do the
feminine stuff like all the female stuff
from very young so i feel like i'm gonna
be mutual in this i'm not gonna you know
say yes or no but like i feel like
everyone at a certain stage in their
life to be like like the most basic
things like cooking like you never know
you might be living by yourself for for
years and years how are you going to
survive without knowing the best thing
of cooking an egg you know it's just
like everything
like if you don't know how to take care
of yourself like
you shouldn't be dating but you'll be
working on yourself
like go read the book
clothes learn how to clean your room
yeah could i ask a follow-up question
so like you like said oh like is it
attractive when women have like those
feminine qualities but also okay is it
attractive when women are you know that
independent
can take care of herself like doesn't
need no doesn't eat anyone but with you
know wouldn't mind being with another
person i feel like i feel like with the
with the whole like oh i'm an
independent like at a certain age right
like when you're young and you're like
okay you've got your business going
you're working hard and you're making
your own money you're you've really
earned as an independent woman and i i
respect that you do your own thing you
know you go to work nine to five
whatever you do and you come back home
you pay the bills when you take care of
your own right i respect that right but
then at a certain age every woman i feel
like they're going to come to a time
where it's like it's honestly i need a
man but like i just i would rather you
know not be alone type thing
right so it's like it is attractive to a
certain extent but like when they start
going with like no no it's one of those
things it's like you got to be open to
let someone help you yeah like yeah you
just like you can be independent i i
respect yeah but you got to be always
open to be like listen like because you
will need something yeah you know you
might be good at old like
abcd and efg and then the rest you will
need someone to help you but you won't
accept the help because in your mind
you're an independent woman so you don't
mind the independence but you would like
them to accept the help if you were to
offer it probably yeah i'll tell you
like that yeah
so i'm gonna go back a couple of
questions and then come back to you in a
minute okay so the question your works
is if men find it attractive if women
can cook and what have you
so i find it i find it quite interesting
that
you that you said that how come you said
that yeah when you were to cook
and you said everyone should cook as
well but when we asked questions about
should men be able to be
masculine in terms of building things it
was like yes they should be so my my my
takeaway from that is that you prefer
meant to keep those traditional
masculine type roles but wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait time
can you land
when
when it came to the flip side yeah you
weren't you didn't
see the sameness so the same
the same energy no i didn't came to the
women
i love femininity like 100 like i said
before that i believe that women should
be a bit more like embrace terminating
more so i'm all for femininity and
masculinity
so when we came to men doing things it
was [ __ ] years attractive sex yeah 120
but if but you when it came to women
cooking it was that what everyone should
cook no because cooking is different
like skills yeah because building a
house is something you don't do like all
the time cooking is something you do
like three times a day so if you can't
cook when you've been doing it three
times a day like your whole life then
like you can't actually live by yourself
you can't be autonomous but building a
house is not something you have in your
daily routine so that's why i wouldn't
say it's like a necessity to do would
you say it was back to traditional
traditional
gender roles traditional gender roles
that men can boo use their hands and
women in the kitchen i think it's
traditionally masculine i think that is
attractive in itself but i don't think
that takes away from the fact that
everyone should know how to cook and
clean because cooking and cleaning is
something that everyone requires in
their day-to-day life you're missing the
point i make i'm not saying that you
shouldn't do it but the energy you gave
when we talk about how men should be
when christian was asked what should man
be mexican and can build it and stuff it
was like [ __ ] yeah energy was there
but it wasn't the same energy when it
was came to cooking was like war let's
do things equally because it wasn't like
mensch it was you didn't say you didn't
say oh everyone should go to when we
show up to put houses it was yes men
that's a turn-off for me it's a question
where it's different the question is
always attractive if a man can build a
house he didn't ask if the question was
is attractive a woman can build a house
right that's right you can build a house
my pants would drop so far would be
halfway through
a woman
i'm sorry yeah like if a woman can do
something as well like it's it's just as
impressive as a man can do it i'm just
saying like because my sexuality is
towards men i'm heterosexual i like men
then obviously it's attracted to me if a
man can build a house because if it
won't keep the house great we can be
best friends but like
it's different so my takeaway is that
equality you don't want equality it's
not to do with equality i think you're
missing the point if it was equal you
would have the equal injury but if you
would have said you would have said
they're different tasks so like eating
and cooking for yourself you require at
least three times a day like living by
yourself so if i want to date someone
that can live autonomously by themselves
they should know how to cook minimum but
building a house that's something that's
on top that's an extra quality that
someone has acquired and learnt to do
that's outside the normal level of what
normal people do so like cooking
everyone should know how to do so i
expect that but when someone can build a
house it's like oh i didn't expect that
you can do that that's amazing you have
this extra skill that you have acquired
in your own time that's two different
things i think it is typically masculine
but that he can do that it's just just
unlike a cherry on the top like someone
has a quieter skill it can be anything
doesn't have to be building a house per
se but like if someone's made the effort
to acquire something and master
something is really attractive so it
could be a language it could be another
skill but i'm just saying that a house
is like very impressive because i can't
i can't do that and i don't know anyone
that can so when someone says that i'm
like wow
so bring houses isn't really an
additional skill it's something you do
you don't want to says no one no one
works uh no one's uh no one generally
generally speaking no one's a a nurse a
male nurse and then
on the side builds houses at the same
time yeah you're a house builder that's
why i'd be shocked when they can do it
you know so you did if someone was a
house he's a he's a builder by trade but
my point trying to make his
level
level of energy was different you you
didn't say oh it'd be great
if women could do it as well but when it
came to cooking it was that woman
mentioned to do it as well as a woman
and that's okay because cooking is not
like a generative like cooking it has
nothing to do with why is that building
gender defined i even define it as a
gender question where you answered it
you defined it as jesus no the question
was do you find it extracted from men
build houses the question to us was is
it attractive a woman can cook and your
answer do you answer the saying that
everyone should be to cook yeah because
everyone should be able to cook but and
why is there any question it will be
able to build a house because you all
live in houses right no one asked that
question i think it would be great if
anyone could build houses no but the
question was is it attractive and men do
it and you don't say it's attractive
but did it too but
when women cook i'm here
i hear what you're saying i'm hearing
you're saying that because i'm attracted
to men obviously i'm attracted to when
they do things and that men are doing
those things if you say like oh women
are doing this traits great but like i'm
not attracted to them sexually because
they're doing those traits because i'm
attracted to men so regardless if a
woman can cook or if she can build a
house i'm more attracted to men that
build a house and can cook because i'm
attracted to men period so that i think
i think the point is like he's saying
you expect one from one gender and you
don't expect one from the other and the
reason is like because people order
takeout people you have no you don't
have to order friends you can do a meal
and building a house is huge well i mean
i mean
we could we could take it down a notch
and maybe not say build a house but like
fix fix something like i personally i
can't fix that cabinet right there and
if anyone knows how to like you baby
girl
what
don't worry i got you i found my drill
don't worry i got it no but i think
again i think the point he's making is
one is like it's just kind of the world
we live in where men are expected to do
things and like women aren't and it's
almost insulting
you can choose
there's no there is no obligation you're
saying
you're saying you can you haven't seen
you haven't said you've used the words
exactly but you're saying it
we're obligated to be traditional men
we're obligated to do no one's overly
things no one's obligated but it's just
my friends
she's saying
this is that whole ammo i'm a woman
thing where it's like oh darling can you
open my like the jar of mayonnaise or
something like that that's just like
oh i can't do it you pass it on and he's
like oh and then he's like all right
and you're looking at him differently
you know i mean that's that's what
that's what i'm getting from that
i don't know i feel like oh
i got it
i feel like that was good but it's a
little okay change to change the topic
can you cook yes
like actually yeah like actually can you
cook
no actually don't always die i know i
don't answer that can you come i know i
just peanut cooking salmon on our stores
and cook
something to say right like if you see
right let's for example um you can if
i'm in the room can cook right yes and
let's say for example you meet someone
right like you meet another person right
and then
they bring your like you've dated them
for like x amount of time right not
enough to bring he him to bring you over
to his right and you trust him enough to
go right and then you would like and
instead of like would it be more
attractive yeah if he's like listen
we're not going to go out we're going to
come back to my house and i'm going to
make you dinner like would you find that
more or more more attractive than a man
if he was like listen we're not gonna
we're gonna skip the movies we're gonna
skip whatever we was gonna do we're
going to come back to my place we're
going to have some wine i'm going to
i'm as a man i'm going to cook i think
that's quite attractive i think i'm a
big foodie and i think that's quite
attractive when someone is is the food
good yeah
well i'm not exactly going to all the
popeyes chicken i'm
you know regardless like whether it's
good or not i think it's really
attractive because like it just kind of
shows like the initiative yeah
initiative the effort is put in and you
know you're trying to like kind of kind
of personalize someone yeah and you're
like hey like let's just have a night
like by ourselves without like you know
yeah i think it's kind of romantic
actually yeah but i think that
i mean the cooking thing i feel like
this cooking idea like oh like oh can a
woman cook can the woman do this so can
a man cook it's really annoying because
cooking isn't that hard like i don't
know what like most people are cooking
but i don't feel like the general skills
required to cook is very difficult like
baby cooking hopes and dreams
that's what they'd be cooking yeah yeah
like if you want to go like a simple
pasta like you just got to put the
kettle on put the pot on the stove and
put the pasta in there and wait 10
minutes like you don't really have to do
that much like when people say they
can't cook it's like you're going out of
your way not to learn like your mom was
like oh let me show you well i know but
some people just get taken out
some guys like like my dad okay like if
he was single okay he he would never
learn how to cook because he works 80
hours a week if you're working at eight
hours a week i do not expect you to cook
because cooking takes time oh yeah but
that's that's what i'm saying like like
it doesn't because you're saying it just
to be alive you have to cook but i'm
saying some people it doesn't fit in
their lifestyle they just order knowing
how to use certain things i feel like
knowing how to use a pan i haven't used
like no one had to use an oven like to
put like a mic like a meal and
it's pretty basic knowledge like i feel
like it wouldn't take you that long to
figure out and when someone says i can't
do that it's kind of like
well you can like spend five minutes and
work it out and you you could but the
thing is like if if we're if we're
talking about cooking right like the way
the way i take cooking right is like
look it's it's one thing to like when
when
a recipe yeah like no no no no no no no
no it's not it's not it's not even about
following the recipe
cooking for me uh like i've i've been
i've been i've learned how to cook like
from a very young age right but the
thing is like
for cooking for me is like making
something out of nothing so like you
take the most basic ingredients like the
most basic spices and you make something
right ready to eat meals or something
that you stick in the microwave for five
minutes is not considered cooking to me
cooking to me is something like if i was
to make a pizza i will not go and buy
pre-made dough i will make the dough
myself that's cooking you know what i
mean that's cooking okay i see what you
mean but like the skills required to
make a dough isn't that difficult like
you just need to weigh some like some
like
flour okay okay
maybe something
how do you make dough how do you make
those yeah like flour
water yeast oil salt maybe pepper if you
want to have some spices in there okay
you leave it for a while to like grow
okay and then you put it out and then
you roll it out but i just feel like
most of these things come with easy eggs
but you pretty much spot on but like you
have eggs and pizza though
a little bit
so like i feel like those skills
required aren't that difficult like
modern society you can google something
it'll take like five minutes to figure
out like to weigh something to put it in
the oven i like the skills required i
feel like everyone should be able to
figure that out like basic like google
stuff like that and speaking of and
speaking of like that yeah like cooking
in in itself nowadays right i feel like
the reason the reason why i feel like
everyone should be able to cook is
beautiful like the in like
back back like 30 40 when internet
wasn't a thing they really needed to use
the cook recipe book and most people
saying like women you should have a
cookbook you don't have to have a cook
but the internet is limitless it's free
it's
it's there for you to find out if you
want to how to if you if you want to
know how to cook a simple thing as
lasagna is go on how to cook it and i
also think like it's a sign of like if
you don't have to cook it like you're
not a foodie and i'm a big food product
i love food and if you're saying to me
like you don't know how to make a basic
lasagna or basic pasta like it's just
telling me that you don't enjoy the food
like i know you go home you eat dry rice
i just i think i just i really i really
think the point is you expect one thing
from men and you don't expect it like
from women i expect that from both
genders that we both know no no i know
but yeah it's this i don't expect us
both to know to build a house i don't
expect both of us to have like a really
rare skill right that's what like okay
i'll give you some i'll give you a small
scenario right your man works let's say
you're in a relationship yeah your mom
works let's say you're like
50 hours a week which is which is a
pretty decent so i work in construction
right
he expects
he doesn't expect but like it should it
shouldn't be
said but like
a hot meal at the end of the day like he
wants to come back the last thing he
wants to do is come back home uh make
food take a shower what he wants to come
to come back to you is you know come
back to you give you a kiss on the cheek
i'm going to take a shower no i
completely i completely agree i was in a
relationship where the person was
learning a lot more than me and i didn't
work
and i was like okay then i'm going to
cook like you're not gonna come home and
have to cook after all that whole like
whole day of work like if you're earning
for both of us then i'm gonna cook for
both of us like you gotta do what you're
good at and do what now bring what you
can bring to the table like just make
like just be fair like i don't
understand like why people wanna get
into relationships that like
unfair for them like i don't understand
like why would you why would you seek
that like for men too like why would you
seek a woman that doesn't want to bring
anything to your relationship i think
that's like for both people to look at
not just men or women i feel like both
should look at like are they bringing
anything
do you enjoy do you value them like i
feel like both people are responsible
for finding that so i thought you can't
just like blame women like oh like she
doesn't want to do this this isn't this
but like you let her because you
continue to
i don't know like do you have that same
energy for men or for women that allow
like men to do certain things yeah like
if the woman is like earning her money
and she's doing her thing she's working
hard and it may be more than the man
then like maybe the man should stay at
home and cook and
help the relationship and help things
more and easier like from the household
it's not i'm sorry that's not enough in
some cases but like not in a lot of men
that's not us that's not a nature like
for example she asked a very good
question from me i think it was last
podcast right she was like
i think it was like um something about
them like the money-wise like would you
be uh
a stay-at-home husband or if you're if
so if your wife or partner earns more
than you and she asks you to be a stern
husband like basically she's a
breadwinner yeah would you want to be
that right absolutely not i would say no
absolutely no purely for the fact that
like i like making my own money because
that money is my money it's not it's not
hers if i honestly if i ask my woman to
just continuously oh you stay at home
i'm gonna you know give you like an
allowance that just makes me feel like
i'm some you know i can't take care of
myself i would i like making my own
money i can understand that like in the
same way you don't want to be that role
like i really look forward to being like
a stay-at-home mom like i look forward
to having a kid and staying home with my
kid and spending time with my kid and
like doing that having that experience
of them growing up and being at home i
was like maybe guys are just built
different it's just one different it's
like interesting because i feel like
what you say you want and what you
actually want are like so different
like
like i i like it just seems like you
kind of want the traditionally masculine
guy but you're still pushing for men to
be feminine when you say what you want
like emotionally available but i just i
have a feeling that that would turn you
off i feel like it's not mutually
exclusive i feel like i'm probably
looking for something that's probably
unideal probably unrealistic right i
will say that now like i'm looking for
someone that can be masculine and
emotional at the same time which is
probably really hard to ask
i just don't think that's real maybe
it would be interesting if that was
around like interesting type of
relationship that could offer both
masculinity and both well that's the
emotional issue it's like a guy asking
you to be masculine and feminine yeah
but i think women do have that kind of
range i think women can be
i'm not saying that when men ask for
that i'm just saying that women have
that range you're asking for a romantic
you're asking for a man to be messy and
effeminate i'm not asking for a
masculine feminine masculinity
where are you going
but yeah i think yeah pearl's probably
right with the unrealistic aspect i feel
like i expect like a really like ideal
world as just not the reality but like
isn't it nice to expect things i feel
like having expectations is nice and
hopes is like nice i feel like you
shouldn't be so nihilistic about things
that you guys expect traits in women
that probably aren't realistic like
maybe you expect i don't think men do
i'm gonna be honest i don't i think
people stand as like my standards are
like meh it's like it's like literally
like don't be fat
like don't be fat be attractive um be
nice to me and like act like you like me
but like don't you think it's sad that
like men don't care if you're
intelligent yeah because like i feel
like men don't like it i think you know
what honestly i think it i think in a
wife like sometimes they want someone
smart raising the kids
they're not someone intellectually i
don't know like
i don't think i think a lot of times
when girls say intelligence they kind of
mean a headache and they like to argue
no i'm sorry
i agree with that i'm saying you can
disagree with me but like personally
myself i don't know if you agree with
this but i find intelligent sexy like if
a woman if a woman knows her [ __ ]
what you're confusing is that a person
has been being intelligent and being
argumentative no no i'm not confusing
those i'm confused like okay like a
woman that's academically smart and the
woman that's not academically supposed
to i think because someone would have
meant for me
i think because like some of the dumbest
people i know are academically smart
no i swear to god
no because like they think they're so
like they're so intellectual but they
have no common sense i do that's true
like street smarts that's what it is no
people that are really like well
educated like that do phds tend to work
people with phds
arguing
no no you have them arguing of men or
men and women or women like that's the
type of idiots you have in academia
sorry
what
no i wasn't talking about that i was
talking about the trans like college
thing yeah but
like that's what i mean like some of the
smart like the smartest people have no
common sense and just like to argue yeah
and i think that's what like like
arguments tonight just like yeah but
it's not like what a man like do you
think like men are attracted to it like
actual intelligence and women are women
that are academically smart like women
that like i don't know that like to have
intellectual conversations so
i think i think i mentioned hey i wasn't
talking to someone else it might be
enough conversation but
a couple of things that work well in
relationships and especially if you're
wearing children as well so
dual parent house
households children have better life
outcomes
when your partner the mother is uh
highly intelligent the children
therefore put not normally because she
imparts is only the woman who dropped it
in part wisdom and into the children so
they if she's intelligent then the
children will be intelligent so the
answer should answer your question is no
men not men are not men are attractive
to women that are intelligent whoever
what what normally comes with women that
that can be intelligent or especially
women our bosses and
what have you have a have personality
traits that surpass like not that
attractive not attractive exactly so
that's why i can understand so we often
get confused yes i'm intelligent but you
don't need to be discussing intelligent
and no stuff so it's a bit like a
like who is leading this household
it's because there's a difference
there's a difference between being
intelligent and being disagreeable
because the trait disagreeable it's um
like i'll give you an example i i was
never really picked for captain
positions yeah because i'm i'm an
agreeable person like if i take a
personality test i'm at 70th percentile
in agreeableness so that means like if i
hired someone i would have a really hard
time firing them
it's going to be difficult yeah and fire
them
let the weak ones go but but what i'm
saying is like is is for someone that's
disagreeable they're like no quick i'm
gonna do it like that's that's the
decision i'm making and disagreeable
people make better bosses
and so and so because they're quick with
decisions
and they're not afraid to tell you how
it is where agreeable people like tend
to sugarcoat it they're a little bit
nicer and so men are more attracted to
agreeable women that are just nice and
want to follow i don't know go to work
and come home and everything we
everything every decision made has to be
discussion
i'll come home and say or win whatever
we're doing i'm gonna buy a new house
we're gonna go on holiday whatever you
know everything needs to be a 20-minute
discussion of the pros and cons or the
ins and outs what we're doing it's just
we're doing this let's go
but women who are disagreeable and
sometimes bosses and very highly
intelligent want to discuss everything
and there's not there's not always a
need it's it's tiring it's draining to
have to always
lay out every single step so what you're
saying is like the typical intelligent
woman is not really attractive to men no
no i said sometimes what i said i didn't
say i said when i said men are attracted
to intelligence because we know
those of us the kind of men you want to
be with not all of us the kind of men
you want to be with
will find that attractive but what a lot
of women confuse and conflate has been
intelligent and been disagreeable and
the two things are different what you
find a lot of telling women are
disagreeable and that's not good so a
lot of intelligent women are
disagreeable as like the general
consensus here and because of that
reason
generally men won't find intelligent
women attracting kind of the correlation
i would guess that it's more like the
intelligent women that tend to make a
lot of money
that's what i would say because everyone
that
doesn't really need to take [ __ ] from
anyone so she probably wouldn't
compromise no no i think no no it's it's
again disagreeable people make better
bosses
so so if you want to if you want to make
a ton of money like the only way to make
a ton of money is to be able to hire
people like eve even now like with this
channel like i've just started bringing
other people on and i'm telling you like
like this is something that i'm really
working to get better at because it
doesn't come naturally to me like
leading people bossing them around
telling them what to do i just want to
be like oh do whatever you want you know
yeah it's it doesn't come naturally like
assertiveness yeah
right like delegation right
right right so so women that are
disagreeable aren't attractive to men
and that's who makes the most money
because you make the most money and
hiring people so we see a combination
with high earning women and
disagreeableness yes and men not
following them attractive that's what
we're doing here but if you have an
intelligent like mother like like you
i'm sure you can think of some woman in
your family who didn't make a lot of
money but is one of the smartest people
you know yeah yeah of course right of
course they've got their own
organization they can run a whole
household they've got the whole thing
going i respect that 100 percent i don't
know your cultural background but my
parents my captain is caribbean and mum
my mom would say one thing you should
say she's a lot of these old caribbean
sayings but one she thinks you said the
time is two bulls can't rule one pen
okay it's like too many chefs will spill
the buff kind of thing so one of you can
you both can't be the boss boss one of
you has to
submit an officer if you or if you're a
disagreeable person then it's not going
to work in the relationship one of you
has got to do to lead
okay
i do i don't know
both can't be going head on all the time
i do i do think like this that needs to
be some sort of balance i did grow up in
like a quite christian household and i
do think that that kind of follows like
someone's going to be the head of the
household and that's normally like the
father figure the male figure in the
house like someone's making the leading
decisions i do think that it's important
that there's always someone you can go
to that has a decisive answer and can
lead but i just i just i do feel like
sometimes
the intelligence of the woman is wasted
sometimes because that role is kind of
normally generally pushed through just
because just because the lead the man is
a lead and he's making a decision
doesn't mean that your your input is not
important i think a lot of time when
people hear submissive they think that
oh i have to shut up i can't say a word
i've got to just listen you know what i
didn't even think about that but it's
just me you have a captain of an
airplane you have a captain in the boat
yeah vice captain you have a president
in the country of a prime minister
country they all have advisers to give
information and provide information it's
him it's within that leader that captain
that president
to absorb the information and make a
decision based on what information
experts say so just because he's a lead
doesn't mean your voice isn't the input
isn't there but what we're saying is
stop don't there's no need to be
sometimes decisions you made
don't i don't have to spend i don't want
to have to every time this is made i
have to explain to you the steps the
process
with the program sorry some jobs but you
know what he said sometimes uh like the
world leaders right sometimes they
they're just a face it's uh in some
cases
they're not even making this yeah the
advisors are the ones that sometimes
i'll be making the big like decisions
because the advisors there's more than
one person in a room talking about it
and then again then when the lead the
actual world leader which is the face of
the country it's a smaller choice
between these two options we've already
decided
yeah okay that's quite interesting i
didn't think of it like that way but i
do think yeah like circle back to the
beginning of this question is like do
men like intelligent women it's like
what is like what is your final answer
on that is that like is that yeah that's
the short answer was yes but we don't
like we don't like disagreeable women we
don't like disabilities okay men don't
like disagree about women it's just one
thing you take away from that that's one
thing you should look okay interesting
interesting i'm gonna